So it's going to turn out that I can complete the definition of expand
with just 2 lines if I use yielding generators and list comprehensions later on.
Let's go take a look and see how this goes.
Well, we're passed in a set of tokens like "a exp,"
and now we're going to consider each possible position,
the zeroth position which is a, and the first position which is exp,
and then for each rule in the grammar, we want to see if it matches.
Now remember, none of the rules in our grammar match a,
so we're going to need our program to deal with that correctly.
If tokens[pos] might be a the first time and exp the second time.
We have to check and see if that matches the left-hand side
of the grammar rule and remember--let's go back up to our encoding of the grammar--
we always had the left-hand side as the zeroth element of this tuple,
and the right-hand side was the first.
We're going to check and see if these strings equal exp.
Only if they do do we want to apply
the transformation, so if we're in the right position,
like we're in position 1, and we see an exp, great.
Now what I need to do is for each of the rules in our grammar,
yield or return one of those results.
Conveniently, we've got this other for loop up here.
For each rule in our grammar, I'm going to use this expression that I showed you before,
and we take tokens 0 through the position.
For us that's that a that's being unchanged.
We're just carrying that along. I'm going to yield that.
We're going to add to it the right-hand side of the rule,
expression plus expression, expression minus expression,
and then also any tokens that came afterward.
We could have done a expression b, and we would have seen a b
on the right-hand side of all of these.
And actually, that's pretty much it, but here's the real power of this.
Let's expand the depth up to 2 and start seeing
what kind of answers we'll get, so now we're going to re-expand
expression, expression, expression.
There are 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 places we could do this expansion.
It's immense. It goes down quite a ways.
But you can start seeing much more complicated expressions,
like for example, here we have something that might be
1 + 2 + 3, but one line below it
1 + 2 - 3.
Here we've got some uses of parentheses to help remove ambiguity,
and you could imagine that I could go up to depth 3 and depth 4
and start enumerating lots of strings in this grammar.
In fact, wow, there's a huge amount of output,
and that's why I was suggesting that this is not a very efficient way of doing things
because I could enumerate a lot of strings of length 3 or 4 or 5
or a lot of strings that have involved 3 or 4 or 5 rule rewrites.
So we just saw a slow way to encode formal grammars in Python
and enumerate strings in them.
We will definitely need this power, but in our next exciting episode
I'm going to teach you a more efficient way
to encode grammar rules, like the rules for HTML in JavaScript
that we will need for our web browser, and check to see if a string is valid
without having to enumerate all possible strings first,
because that might take, let's say, one more second than I have,
so we're going to see very efficient ways to solve this problem.
Super cool. Stick around, and I'll see you next time.